Diese Schweine leben nur, um später gegessen zu werden. Aber bis es soweit ist, soll es ihnen gut gehen.
Gleich ist die Linse schmutzig.
Aber so ein bisschen ist das ja schon auch Utopia hier jetzt.
Natürlich, aber warum nicht?
98 Prozent der Schweine in Deutschland leben anders. Sie stehen in konventionellen Ställen.
Da geht es um Masse und um Effizienz. Eine Sache, die wir alle wissen, aber gerne verdrängen.
Ich weiß natürlich, dass diese Art der Haltung weit weg ist, von dem Was natürlich ist –
was wir den Schweinen antun. Ich sage aber nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Die Schweine haben alles, was sie brauchen.
Der eine hat etwa 4.000 Schweine. Der andere knapp 50.
Es sind zwei Welten. Wir verlassen Utopia wieder und schauen uns heute mal die konventionelle Mast an.
Denn seit dem Corona-Ausbruch bei Tönnies diskutiert Deutschland über Fleisch. Mal wieder.
Florian Hollmann ist 28 Jahre alt und konventioneller Schweinehalter. Er mästet knapp 4.000 Schweine.
Er nimmt uns mit dem Handy mit in den Stall und zeigt uns, wie es seinen Tieren geht.
Die freuen sich auch schon alle, dass es losgeht.
Vor einem Jahr hat er den Hof übernommen und mästet Schweine konventionell,
aber mit der freiwilligen “Initiative Tierwohl“.
Das heißt, seine Schweine haben unter anderem 20 Prozent mehr Platz als gesetzlich vorgeschrieben,
etwas um sich zu kratzen, Beschäftigungsmaterial und eine Kühlung.
Sie stehen aber ohne Stroh auf den Gitterböden und haben kein Außengehege.
Die wiegen so 80 kg. Die gehen zum Schlachter, wenn die so 120 kg haben.
Für uns ist ein normaler Rhythmus, dass wir einmal in der Woche Schweine verkaufen.
Das ist immer ein LKW voll, das sind so 170 Stück.
Sein Hof war von der Schließung bei Tönnies direkt betroffen.
Hunderte schlachtreife Tiere wurden nicht wie geplant abgeholt.
Ein Schwein lebt ja von der Besamung bis es geschlachtet ungefähr ein Jahr.
Diese Vorlaufzeit die habe ich. Wenn ich diesen Prozess in Gang gesetzt habe,
dass ich die Sau besamt habe, die Ferkel geboren werden und ich das Tier ernährt habe -
das dauert halt ein Jahr und das kann ich schlecht voraussehen.
Und das ist eigentlich diese Problematik, die wir gerade haben.
Dass wir nicht eben den Prozess wie eine Firma die Autos herstellt
für zwei, drei Wochen pausieren können, weil wir sagen, es wird jetzt gerade nicht so viel abgenommen.
Wir sind in dieser Produktion drin.
Das was wir angefangen haben, müssen wir auch zu Ende bringen.
Eine hochspezialisierte just-in-time-Produktion wie auch auf diesem Hof.
Dass einen Monat lang nicht geschlachtet wurde, sorgte für Stau im Stall.
Es kamen neue Ferkel nach, aber die alten waren noch nicht weg.
Rund 400.000 Tiere standen in der Warteschlange.
Für uns als Tierhalter ist es deswegen so prekär, weil unsere Schweine zu schwer werden.
Wir wollen als Verbraucher immer ein Schnitzel haben, das gleich groß ist.
Und dafür brauche ich auch immer ein Schwein, das gleich schwer ist.
Im Durchschnitt isst jede und jeder Deutsche etwa 60 kg Fleisch pro Jahr.
2019 wurden in Deutschland 760 Millionen Tiere geschlachtet. Davon waren 55,1 Millionen Schweine.
Tönnies schlachtet im Hauptwerk pro Tag zwischen 20.000 und 30.000 Tiere.
Die großen Schlachthöfe haben genaue Größenvorgaben und wollen einen bestimmten Fettgehalt.
Zu große und fette Schweine sind weniger wert.
Vor dieser ganzen Geschichte haben wir so ungefähr 200 € für ein Schwein bekommen,
jetzt aktuell bekomme ich ungefähr 150€ für ein Schwein. Also 50€, die ich weniger habe.
Dazu kommt, dass ich das Schwein noch ein bisschen länger gefüttert habe, es länger im Stall hatte.
Haben die Schweine gerade was zu essen bekommen?
Ja genau. Die kriegen gerade was zu fressen.
Ja ist ja wirklich Halli Galli im Stall, wenn die was zu Fressen bekommen.
Ja, das ist kein Witz. Wenn du die auf Diät setzt. Also das werde ich immer wieder gefragt:
“Dann gib denen doch nichts zu fressen, dann wachsen die auch nicht.” Aber das geht nicht.
Gibt es etwas, was Du dir in der Diskussion von Verbrauchern und Verbraucherinnen wünschst?
Mehr Ehrlichkeit. Also im Einkaufsverhalten.
Nicht nur der Wunsch vor dem Supermarkt nach mehr Tierwohl, sondern auch an der Kasse halt.
Dass das eben umgesetzt wird. Im Moment sehe ich einfach noch, dass der Verbraucher halt
viel günstiges Fleisch essen möchte, kaufen will. Für die Leute produziere Ich.
Ich bin froh um Jeden, der irgendwie Wertschätzung bringt und auch teures Fleisch kauft.
Ich bin da überhaupt nicht böse und ich sehe das auch nicht als persönliche Kritik an oder so.
Ich stell einfach nur fest, dass der Verbraucher so tickt
und anscheinend an der Theke entscheidet: "Das System finden wir gut".
Und das, obwohl den meisten Menschen klar ist, das System ist schlecht für Tiere, Menschen und Umwelt.
Regelmäßig gibt es schlimme Berichte und Bilder. Aus allen Teilen der Produktion.
Tönnies ist ein Beispiel. Ein anderes sind solche Zahlen:
Jedes Jahr schaffen es 13 Millionen Schweine nicht einmal zum Schlachthof, sondern landen im Müll.
Der Druck in der Branche ist groß. Seit 2010 hat ein Drittel der Schweinehalter aufgehört.
In immer weniger Ställen stehen immer mehr Tiere.
Ich frage mich auch oft so: In der ganzen Diskussion darüber - wie werden Schweine gehalten,
wie ist es in der industriellen Produktion - würde ich das machen wollen?
Warum bin ich Landwirt? Es mach ultra viel Spaß. Die Vielseitigkeit, der Umgang mit den Tieren,
das gibt richtig viel zurück. Klar der Druck ist hoch und der Druck wächst, also er steigt.
Ich habe mich freiwillig dazu entscheiden. Ich bin seit einem Jahr im Betrieb.
Mein Vater hat den Betrieb von seinem Opa übernommen, er hat ihn entwickelt –
so, wie es eben in der Zeit typisch war, was eben erfolgversprechend war.
Ich fang gerade an. Wer weiß, was ich in 10 Jahren darüber sage.
“Überleg mal dein erstes Jahr als Du angefangen hast, war die Corona-Krise.
Guck mal wie wir da die Schweine gehalten haben, wie machen wir's heute?”
Einige Höfe und Initiativen setzen bereits auf mehr Tierwohl mit Auslauf und Stroh.
Mehr Geld gibt es dafür aber oft nicht. Für Florian Hollmann kommt es deshalb nicht in Frage.
Der ehemalige Sterne-Koch Franz Keller hat dafür wenig Verständnis und fordert einen radikalen Wandel.
Deshalb muss man die gesetzlichen Vorgaben so machen,
dass man sich das, dass der Bauer sich das leisten kann.
Und die Bauern machen alles mit, wenn sie damit Geld verdienen können damit.
Aber wenn man ihnen halt die Möglichkeit gibt, auch mit schlechter Qualität Geld zu verdienen,
dann tun sie das auch. Ganz einfach.
Zu ihm und seinen bunten Schweinen kehren wir in unserem nächsten Film zurück.